the best electric can-opener if you're
looking for the best electric can-opener
here's a collection you've got to see
don't lecture me you can open frozen
bodies slicing a man in half and one of
the most unfair knife vs. samurai sword
fights I've ever seen I'll say you've
flied knife each Pony before we have the
second last episode of season 3 with
still many unanswered questions and
theories to discuss so stick around as
we take a deep dive into the episode and
explain what was in Musashi's briefcase
the fate of Bernard and Stubbs and
what's next for Caleb we begin with a
Rehoboam circle picking up a divergence
in Jakarta Indonesia remember after the
death of Maeve in the distillery that
Ciroc was able to determine where the
Dolores copies were located with one of
them being in Jakarta this one was
Musashi bonus points if you were able to
recognize the Hindu God in the
background here in Hinduism gods with
many arms are able to perform multiple
tasks at a time just like how Dolores is
able to do the same with her copies
Musashi hands over a briefcase to be
delivered to a quote friend leading me
to believe that what's inside is going
to the final Dolores copy in Berlin that
we haven't seen yet Musashi receives a
call from Charlotte she's masked and
shadow here but you can slightly make
out part of her charred skin on the side
so either she has the world's best
makeup artist or has gotten some medical
help we've seen these devices heal up
wounds so that may have played a part
Charlotte tells Musashi that Dolores his
plan involves all of them to die so
she's gone ahead and leaked his location
to either made or serac since they
control Clementine and hinari oh the two
resurrected hosts built to aid Maeve in
her battle against Dolores notice how
these two make off with Musashi's head
likely so they can retrieve Dolores as
pearl for further interrogation
something that was cut short last
episode
Caleb's arc deals with him coming to
terms with the reality of his past we
see a woman here known as dr. green
treating Caleb with augmented reality
therapy the same therapy William was
treated with last episode we get flashes
of him by the ocean where he'll
supposedly commit suicide him going
through a forest shooting what appears
to be 8
terrorists in the US town and in Crimea
with Frances before were treated to
another diversions in Sonora Mexico the
place that was the inspiration for
Westworld Kaleb and Dolores travel on
horseback with Dolores carrying the
duffel bag delivered to them at the end
of episode 5 she lies to kill him about
the purpose of her revolution noting
that her people are extinct yet she has
barrels of that white host goop and
Charlotte having apparently uploaded all
the host data to her she theoretically
has the material to rebuild her race but
his setting up kale appear as Bernard
says about Kaleb near the end Loras was
made with a poetic sensibility he won't
destroy humanity he will caleb is merely
a pawn hence why the name of this
episode is passed pawn back at the
re-education facility william learns
that Stubbs is a host and that his blood
was infected with what bernard calls a
virus of sorts this virus was what
charlotte injected him with in order to
find out the location of the sonora
reeducation facility the one where will
meet the predecessor to Rehoboam solomon
bernard also tells him that they have
him down as deceased likely because
william was set to be transferred to the
sonora facility to be put on ice we
learn a little more about Caleb's time
in the military he worked in a unit that
tracked Russian insurgents technology
has improved so much that these glasses
can see specially marked targets which a
satellite can use to deploy missiles
with insane accuracy now it just might
be me but these missiles look a lot like
the arrows found in the intro credits
and on Nathan's bedsheets caleb recounts
the story of him and francis capturing
the leader of the russian insurgency
will later find out this is all a lie a
reprogrammed memory Delores sets up a
sniper rifle from the duffel bag it
contains a drone that is able to map out
and locate all of the security personnel
allowing Dolores to make quick work of
them from a great distance
as we enter inside we can see it as the
same reeducation center Dempsey senior
visited Soraka in Episode five dolores
tells caleb they're here to see solomon
i scrapped predecessor to Rehoboam
who had developed serious anomalies
likely because it
programmers socks brother jean me was
schizophrenic some of that insanity had
manifested in its AI we also see a robot
here the same kind that may've
commandeered when she tried to escape
sir acts labs solomon knows that caleb
is you class a class designated for the
hopeless cases william was designated
you class as well as his therapist we
saw last episode solomon was designed to
create this new world order but it was
also designed with a fail-safe an EMP
electromagnetic pulse that if triggered
would destroy it this is what dolores
uses at the end of the episode she notes
that she's not that different than
solomon hosts were also built with a
fail-safe by their creators as she
touches the back of her spine where
explosives were put in all the hosts
bernard learns more about sir axe plan
he saw that humans couldn't save them
from themselves so he tried to reprogram
them just like hosts but in order to do
that he need high-grade biometric data
data which williams sold to him bernard
chastises william over this and he
responds step back to like I said
Bernard you're not which i think is a
really interesting thing to say
considering Bernard is the only one with
a partly red pearl meaning he is part
host part human data and the dominant
theory out there is that human part is
Arnold we get a glimpse of the fake
memory Caleb was instilled with that his
partner Francis was ambushed and Caleb
ended up killing the attackers we can
tell the fake memory from the real
memory when we put these images side by
side the left is the fake memory with
Cyrillic signage and the right the real
memory with English Caleb and Delores
ventured deeper into the facility
stumbling across a hologram of serac
this dude really loves Holograms this is
a program message meant for jean me his
brother was put on ice until serac could
find a way to reprogram and cure these
outliers as solomon said earlier the
therapy success rate was only one in 10
hence why so many people who weren't
successful were cryogenically frozen
kind of like how hosts who acted up were
put into storage this makes it clear why
serac wants to Loras she has the
encryption key to that high-grade
biometric data that can save his
brother's life not to mention countless
others solomon tries to justify
surak's decision by stating that since
putting these outliers on ice crime and
hunger have plummeted surak's vision of
the world is based on the principle of
utilitarianism the greatest amount of
good for the greatest amount of people
even if that means having to ice
reprogram or kill millions of others we
can see Xiaomi has been given a
prominent ice tomb here in the facility
the circle surrounding him is quite
reminiscent of the circle that surrounds
hosts as they're being made he'll appear
learns his true past he was an outliner
tasked with hunting down other outliers
this was facilitated through the reco
app which he and his partner Francis
would use to commit their crimes when
taking out this man known as Whitman
they put on these masks containing many
eyes just like how the system that
controls them sees everything
Whitman used to work for a
pharmaceutical company that made these
limbic pills he knows about the Sonora
facility and tells them his crime was
asking too many questions
hence why he needs to be taken away for
his cold and nap Maeve arrives just
before Dolores tells Sullivan to give
Kayla what she calls the final strategy
the plan Johnny s almond to make right
before serac put him on ice that plan
whoever was made 15 years ago and much
has changed so Dolores goes off to fight
Maeve while Solomon takes time to
recalibrate this plan to fit the new
world as Dolores prepares to fight Maeve
they have a little back and forth and
Maeve takes this moment to control one
of Sir axe BOTS and snapper the odds are
really stacked against Dolores here
while she gets a dinky knife and sniper
rifle maybe gets his samurai sword and
frickin quadcopter meanwhile William
tells Bernard and Stubbs that he's going
to wipe every host from earth beginning
with the two of them they better kill
him now or he'll kill them later
something he appears to fully live up to
at the end of the episode in Caleb's
memory we learn what really happened
while Francis goes to make a round
Whitman tells him how the system works
it's always listening Rico will offer
them some extra cash to kill the other
partner and seeing how Caleb didn't get
one it's probably him on the chopping
block is Whitman telling the truth or
are these just mind games
Caleb leader confronts Francis asking
him how much he was offered to kill him
to which he responds enough Francis goes
to
but Caleb ends up taking him down he's
so distraught over what he just did that
when Whitman tells him he just became a
very rich man he kills him - caleb is
justifiably mad at Solomon after all it
was through his control that he ended up
murdering his best friend lucky for him
however Dolores's new strategy for
revolution is ready may even Dolores
continued to fight but Dolores gets her
arm blown off by the quadcopter she
rushes back to Solomon with me in
pursuit telling her she's died many
times but this will be her last she also
has a great line about how Dolores has
turned a young man and unleashed his
inner darkness before a reference to
William but before Mafeking killed
Dolores once and for all
Dolores hits the EMP which fries them
all now I hope there's a back-up
generator or all these bodies are gonna
thaw pretty fast but don't fret several
of the previews in season trailers show
another major confrontation between
Maeve and Dolores so these two will be
making another appearance in the finale
in our second last scene bonus points
for those who notice the lab - slab sign
in the background an ad for the kind of
factory made meat like the one bernard
worked at in episode 1 this gas station
here no longer sells fossil fuels the
future is electric you can even see the
charging stations in the background
Bernard and Stubbs make the mistake of
letting William go on his own in the
station where he finds a shotgun
Bernard tell Stubbs that if they can
find Caleb maybe they can stop Dolores
and Bernard shows Stubbs Caleb's
registration number which is the exact
same number as William this could mean
that Caleb's data was tampered with
in an earlier scene we see Stubbs
tinkering around the computer in the
background I've theorized that Stubbs is
serac second mole so it's possible he
has done something here to tamper with
the data ultimately William ends up
holding these two at gunpoint and in the
preview we do see him fire it but at who
we don't know we do know that Stubbs has
been programmed to protect Bernard so I
wouldn't be surprised if he sacrifices
himself his character has pretty much
been a glorified bodyguard the season
with not much to do so I wouldn't be
surprised if he kicks the bucket in this
final episode finally we see Caleb come
across Dolores as deactivated body he'll
be the one to put her together again and
he gets a call from Dolores is a virtual
assistant who says he has instructions
for him these instructions likely have
thing to do with this exoskeleton here
and perhaps that dolores clone in berlin
that we haven't encountered yet but i
want to know your thoughts and theories
in the comments below thanks for
watching everyone please make sure to
LIKE and subscribe and check out my
other videos and Westworld breakdowns
you can also follow me on twitter at
things story whitey
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much